It's ridiculous to use such an old way of doing
things Oh, Dogen isn't doing well. What's
wrong with the
company?
No, that's why it's useless in Japan, isn't it?
I have to go to a drinking party that doesn't have
anything to do with it, and
really, Japan is the only country that has such inefficient
ways of doing things.
At a drinking party,
you're definitely good at chopsticks,
so you think chopsticks only exist in
Japan.
I
can really feel that I'm frustrated
that I'm too
frustrated, but I
don't know what Dogen said just now.
I understand well that Gen is dissatisfied with the current situation, and
if I were in the same position, I would feel the same dissatisfaction,
but that's why it's no good, isn't it?
Even though
my company is a Japanese company,
we don't use faxes at all. It's a lie.
No, I think that's what I've been told by young people, so
how many people are 2 now
?  There
may be any number of Japanese people who are resisting that trend,
but then answer me
, who are the Japanese in the framework of Japan
?  If it's
everyone who lives in Japan,
it's Michishita's fault that fax machines still exist.
He has a completely different way of
thinking and doesn't want to listen to me at all.
What did the foreigner say just now